hallo mein name ist luca eine liebe
freundin in einer woche ist halloween
und halloween ist immer ein wenig
gruselig und auch bei mir damals als ich
noch ein kind war war es so dass man
dann in der schüler also nicht auf der
weiterführenden schule sondern eher in
der grundschule und im kindergarten
da hat man dann auch gruselige sachen
gemacht die beispielsweise kürbis
schnitzen sich verkleiden oder auch
gruselige bilder malen und ihr seht
bereits im titel
wir schauen uns heute einige des
putschisten bilder an die kinder
gezeichnet haben das ist das erste bild
das ich heute raus gesucht habe und zwar
sieht es auf den ersten blick relativ
harmlos aus unten steht jedoch today
hätte von time mom and dad and i can't
even the demon left dass landis time
also auf deutsch übersetzt heute hatte
ich einen super coolen tag mit mama papa
und unserer katze und sogar der dämon
der sonst immer dabei ist hat uns heute
mal allein gelassen
und hier sehen wir mama und papa hier
ist er hier ist die katze und damit
schüttet dem und mit mut auf
beim nächsten bild der stadt tatsächlich
aus dem kindergarten und zwar hatte das
mädchen die vorgabe bekommen
beziehungsweise gesagt bekommen mal doch
mal ein foto von dir und deiner besten
freundin und dann hat sie sich selbst
gemalt und daneben ihre beste frau
[Musik]
ich weiß nicht ob man darüber lachen
sollte oder ob man sich ernsthaft
gedanken um das kind du machen sollte
sprachen lernen dass ich mache mir doch
direkt weiter mit der nächsten zeichnung
eines kindes und zwar geht es hierbei
darum dass in einer grundschule gesagt
wurde zeichnet euren rechten
sitznachbarn und dann hätte eigentlich
darf man darüber nicht lachen
auf jeden fall hat ein junger mann seine
sitznachbarin gesprächen wie das übelste
horror monster junge junge junge aber
ich bin ganz ehrlich irgendwie er könnte
auch kunst sein wenn einer dafür wenn
irgendein krasser maler dafür millionen
euro haben will alter würde ich auch
sagen ja das ist das nächste gezeichnete
bild und zwar steht oben geschrieben
manuel wie so proud to meet you sleep
und nun ja er hat sein bruder tim i naja
zum schlafen bekommen dadurch dass er
ihnen erstickt hat mit einem kissen haye
auf was kinder so kommen das ist
wahnsinn
ich meine auch dass hier das ist das
nächste foto ihr seht schon oben miklos
der dance und mamis grave also der junge
und sein vater tanzen auf dem grab der
mutter ich meine
wenigstens hatte die sonne noch was zu
lachen machen wir doch weiter mit der
nächsten gruseligen kinderzeichnungen
zwar dass diese hier
ich glaube das bild sagt schon alles der
titel bzw die überschrift des bildes ist
best friends und die person nicht
gezeichnet hat das recht das mädchen mit
den blonden haaren und links halion
horrors konstrukt aber gut machen wir
weiter mit der nächsten zeichnung und
was es diesmal sogar ein ganzer komik
und zwar trägt der comic die überschrift
halb special editions also halb schlägt
die kardashians und das erste bild des
comics ist
dass die linke person sagte dass gerade
ten also ich hab mich gerade gebräunt
und die rechte person der kardashian
sagte just married seventy 20 minutes
also die beiden mädels freuen sich
jeweils über so komplett irrelevante
sachen die eine hat irgendwie sich
gerade bräunen lassen hat das gut
hingekriegt und die andere personen weit
für 72 minuten verheiratet dann kommt
allerdings hulk rein und nimmt die
beiden und er wirkt die beiden die haare
zu kopf stehen oder blut oben rauscht
ich habe keine ahnung wie man auch so
was kommt aber du kriegst von mir auf
jeden fall der in der woche das ist die
nächste zeitung und zwar ist der crazy
big tower und oben im obersten stockwerk
sich schon ist ja die zeit dort
wir sehen auch links daneben den blau
gezeichnet sehr viele leute darunter
springen unten links ist lava und der
lava geib und unten drin steht der
maniac men und die victims auch an der
stelle würde ich mir auf der einen seite
als elternteil denken mein kind hat eine
menge kreativität auf der anderen seite
würde ich mir dennoch ziemlich starke
sorgen machen das hier ist das nächste
foto und da weiß ich gar nicht wo ich
anfangen soll
ich würde sagen wir schauen uns erst mal
überschrift an und zwar ist das kann die
ballistik also der kannibalische
kannibalistische ich weiß nicht genau
wie das ausgesprochen wird auf jeden
fall der hügel der kannibalen und man
sieht schon darunter werden menschen
gegrillt gegessen menschen über tnt in
die luft gesprengt also auf was kinder
wirklich so kommen ist sie krank machen
wir doch direkt weiter mit dem nächsten
bild und was ist das hier ein mann mit
nur einem arm der in der luft rumspringt
und erfreut sich eigentlich also er hat
einen lachenden mund gezeigt bekommen
von dem kind darunter steht allerdings
ein exit off also die person die das
wild gezeichnet hat hat der person diese
gezeichnet hat den arm abgerissen er ja
mit dir möchte ich eigentlich ungern
schön das hier ist das nächste foto und
zwar ist es eigentlich auch wieder
relativ kreativ das ist nämlich eine
wasserrutsche
oben links ist der staat und unten
rechts ist das ende und oben rechts
steht geschrieben live so what were you
happy end und dann hat die personal dazu
geschrieben you are here da unten
man hat dass seine oma seiner oma bzw
seinem opa geschenkt und will damit
sagen bald bist du tot menschen nicht
gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
haben wir uns mal die nächste
kinderzeichnung an und zwar steht dort
geschrieben hi how are you doing in
hellas johnnie to get also er hat ein
bild für sein vater gezeichnet und fragt
ihn hayta wie geht's dir eigentlich in
der hölle wahrscheinlich sind deine
eltern nicht zu finden
machen wir doch direkt weiter mit der
nächsten kinderzeichnung und zwar
handelt es sich dabei um dieses bild
wird ab mai your sleeping also was
passiert wissen wir wie es aussieht wenn
du während des schlafens aufgeschnitten
wirst ich mein ich selbst ja mal ein
buch herausgebracht mit meiner form
gelegt als er kennt diesen ekelhaften
schmerzt wenn man um klingt alter das
allerdings meine damen und herren ich
selbst habe ja mal ein buch geschrieben
mit meiner mom über mein leben und da
drin sind glaube ich auch zeichnungen
ich als kind gemacht habe und man kann
das mal vergleichen
was ich als kind gezeichnet habe auch
ganz lustig hier habe ich meinen vater
auf den kopf gestellt und dann habe ich
gekocht aber ich will euch einfach nur
mal zum vergleich zeigen hier habe ich
will euch einfach mal zum vergleich
zeigen was ich damals so gezeichnet habe
hier sieht man dass ich habe bäume
gezeichnet oder malen picacho da
irgendwie sowas ein paar sekunden später
vielleicht habe ich dann doch das ein
oder andere komische bild gezeichnet
ich frag mich einfach wollen kinder
damit irgendetwas kompensieren was sie
irgendwie nie so richtig erlebt haben
also wenn kinder beispielsweise nie so
richtig liebe erlebt haben wollen dann
die eltern einfach in der hölle sehen so
wieder das vorhin beispielsweise gezeigt
hat oder ist es das habe ich mich auch
schon gefragt einfach der schlechter
einfluss durch irgendwelche serien die
irgendwie viel zu brutal sind oder
dadurch dass jeder mittlerweile ein
handy hat und sich damit auch videos
angucken kann die eigentlich nur für 18
jährige oder älter als 18 jährige
geeignet sind das wirklich echt mal
interessieren weil besonders wenn ich
mir jetzt beispielsweise die nächste
kinderzeichnungen angucke das soll zum
beispiel ein kind einen weihnachtstraum
zeichnen und ich hätte damals hin gemalt
keine ahnung hier ein playmobil schiff
was ich mir gewünscht habe aber die
person meint einfach das hier
ha ha no mary des mis und dann der
weihnachtsmann mit einer axt und er
selbst wie er dann hätt mir die frage
haben kinder dann die kinder dann so
viel hass in sich drin und zeichnen das
dann
oder ist es einfach ein job ich habe
keine ahnung ich will es auf jeden fall
interessieren die ihr das ganze sehen
könnt ihr mir gerne und in die
kommentare schreiben ich will allerdings
sagen wir machen direkt weiter mit der
nächsten kinderzeichnung hier ist nichts
groß zugeschrieben
allerdings läuft das ding rum wie
irgendein von dämon besessen der mensch
auch entspannt was auch entspannt ist
ist diese karte die tatsächlich ein
junger seiner oma geschrieben hat und
zwar steht love you wanna love you when
you die ja
ja ja aber wenn du dir doch schon zur
drittletzten kinderzeichnung die ich für
heute raus gesucht habe und zweitens
diese hier
this is going to happen to you schreibt
das mädchen und zeichnet sich selbst so
in voll klein mit einem messer an den
hals ihres bruders der da am weinen ist
das hat auch meine schwester für mich
früher zeichnen können glaube ich die
vorletzte kinderzeichnung ich vorher
ausgesucht habe ist diese hier
da steht das ist von abraham die
zeichnung vom 2 september 2012
und die frage ist what will we be doing
the new one hundred years old
unterschreibt breaking out of mind
also dann bricht er aus seinem grab aus
abraham willst du dann zombie werden
wenn du hundert jahre alt bisher was
allerdings war der liebe freunde kommen
wir nun doch schon zur letzten
gruseligen kinderzeitung für das heutige
video uns was ist eine zeichnung die ein
mädchen für ihren kinder aufpasse
babysitter wie auch immer man es nennen
mag gezeichnet hat und zwar hieß der
babysitter valerie und sie hat
geschrieben die ihr valerie get out of
my life und dann hat sie den kopf von
valerie eine axt und den körper von
valerie gezeichnet also wirklich eure
kreativität ist wirklich menschen nicht
gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
an der stelle ist das heutige jetzt
allerdings auch beenden meine lieben
freunde schreibt mir gerne in die
kommentare welche kinderzeichnungen ihr
am komisch zu fandet beziehungsweise am
gruseligsten zudem könnte mir auch gern
mal und in die kommentare schreiben wie
ihr denkt wie ein kind darauf kommt so
etwas zu zeichnen
also das ist wirklich die frage die mich
am meisten beschäftigt jetzt wo ich mir
die ganzen sachen angeschaut habe wenn
euch das video allerdings auf jeden fall
gefallen da würde ich mich über einen
daumen hoch von euch unter dem video
hier freuen abonniert zudem gern meinen
kanalfest noch kein technokrat und was
ich nicht auch mal interessieren würde
wäre schreibt immer gerne in die
kommentare was sich in nächster zeit
hochladen soll
ich habe in letzter zeit 12 instagram
die ms bekommen wo leute die videos sind
zwar lustig wo du hier beispielsweise
auf kinderzeichnung reagiert um zweiter
und so fort aber mach mal wieder sachen
wie frühjahr blabla und da main kanal
wie ich finde
klar auf der einen seite will ich das
hochladen was ich möchte was ich gut
finde auf der anderen seite
da habe ich dann aber auch fast 4
millionen abonnenten die gerade hier
irgendwie meinen kanal abonniert haben
die natürlich auch so ein bisschen mit
entscheiden sollen und auch dürfen was
sich hochladen deswegen was wünscht ihr
euch was ich die nächsten tage wochen
mehr hochladen soll schreibt das auch
gerne in die kommentare und jetzt kommt
das auto
[Musik]